Speaker 1: I would say why don't we speak next
to Ryan from New Hampshire? Ryan, welcome to The
David Pakman Show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hang on. Can you hear me? Yeah. Hey,
I just had a quick question and we talked about
the vaccine and one of your recent shows, but
my dad had said something about like healthy
people who are athletes dying. And I was just
wondering how I could, like, combat that.
Speaker 1: Well, what's the claim that he's
making? He's he's saying athletes have
died. What does he believe they died of?
Speaker 2: He said, Just like cardiac
arrest or myocarditis, I think.
Speaker 1: Okay. Which
athletes died of myocarditis?
Speaker 2: He holds 16,000.
Speaker 1: Sorry, what.
Speaker 2: He just said. I think he read a report
that there was like 24 before COVID a year and
now there's like 16,000 a year.
Speaker 1: 16,000 athletes are
dying of myocarditis. Your dad believes.
Speaker 2: It. That's what he's been told.
Speaker 1: Yeah. There's no I mean, there's just
no evidence of that, you know? We did a story
about this very, very specifically. You've got to
understand the base rate. Okay? 21 million people
aged 18 to 24 received two doses of the vaccine.
21 million people. Just based on general death
rates you would expect in a year. 70,000 of those
people to die. And that includes car accidents,
that that includes everything. Even if even if you
said, oh, but there are ten of these died suddenly
things are 20 or whatever, You know, it does not
tell us anything about the vaccine and it does not
even compare mathematically to the number of those
people you would expect to die. Now, in terms of
cardiac arrest, you know, DeMar Hamlin didn't
die. So even from cardiac arrest, I don't even
know if DeMar Hamlin was vaccinated. I don't even
know that it's been said. I mean, there's just the
problem with this is these people really don't
want to listen. You know, your dad apparently
read somewhere 16,000 people died of myocarditis.
There's no evidence of that. It just seems like he
wants to live in that world. And it's sad.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Well, thank you, David. I
love listening to your show.
Speaker 1: All right, Ryan,
good luck with your dad. That sounds like
a very complicated situation. Remember,
if you would like to get on with me, your
nickname in the waiting lobby should be
your name and where you're calling from or
where you're calling from and your name.
Those are the two important components. Let's
go to our friend Johnny from Boston. Johnny
from Boston. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Happy New Year.
Speaker 1: Likewise.
Speaker 2: Thanks. I
have two questions for you. Well, they can
be summarized in one place. Two candidate
candidates running for 2024 in the Senate, Katie
Porter in California and Lucas Coons in Missouri.
Your opinions on them as potential candidates.
Speaker 1: Don't know a thing about the Missouri
race, to be perfectly frank. I'll have to
inform myself about that. We talked about
the Katie Porter situation earlier this
week on the award winning bonus show. And
I think Katie Porter is fantastic. The one
interesting thing is she's running for Dianne
Feinstein seat. Dianne Feinstein has not actually
said she's retiring in 2024. A lot of signs point
to she should and maybe she will. She would be
close to 95 at the end of the next term if she
were to win. There are concerns about cognitive
decline, her not realizing that she's meeting
people for like the 10th time that she's
met many times asking the same questions
over and over again during hearings. So there's
a lot of a lot of push for Dianne Feinstein to
retire. Putting aside the Feinstein component. I
think Katie Porter is super smart. She's really
good at hearings. She's really good at getting
to sort of distilling the essence of so many
issues. And I would love to see Katie Porter as
the next senator for representing California.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree. She my my dad lives
in her district and which it's Newport Beach,
which is very you know, it's it's country
club Republicans. But she has a way of
getting through to them. And I think I agree. I
think Dianne Feinstein said she had a hard time,
but she's going all the way back to Harvey Milk
like she was the centrist Democrat going against
Harvey Milk in George Moscone. I mean, I think
the time had come through. She set her legacy.
But yeah, it's kind of sad from what I've
heard about how she's just kind of not the
same person who she was even a few years ago.
Speaker 1: So, yeah, she's been in the Senate
30 years. She was, I guess, about 59 when
she went in. She's 89 now. It's quite a
run. It's nothing to be ashamed of, certainly.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah, not at all. And she was mayor
of San Francisco for ten years. But anyway, yeah,
I just wanted to kind of get your perspective. I'm
hoping Katie Porter gets the nomination. I think
she's the perfect person to win in that state, so.
Speaker 1: All right. We will track it closely.
Speaker 2: All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks, Devin. Johnny from
Boston, great to hear from you, as always.